I think that a student should have the
right to hold up an Isis flag I mean it
will stir debate it would be outrageous
but he has the right to do so
constitutionally in October George
Washington University police demanded
student Rami Abu Naja removed the
Palestinian flag hanging from his dorm
window claiming they'd received multiple
complaints from other students
Abu Naja complied with the cops demands
but wondered why the police targeted his
flag for removal and not any of the
other national flags hanging from dorm
windows across campus
I believe that my flag was sticking down
because it was a Palestinian flag you
fart in the direction of Israel you get
a huge backlash university president
Stephen Knapp did eventually apologize
to a vanassa but the incidents still a
reminder of how college students use
police and administrators to censor
people they disagree with left-leaning
commenters like Glenn Greenwald and Matt
Iglesias contend that free speech
advocates overlook the censorship of
pro-palestinian voices the University of
Illinois at urbana-champaign recently
fired professor Stephen Salida for his
anti-israel tweets and the University of
California is attempting to suppress
criticism of the State of Israel as part
of an overly broad restriction of
anti-semitic hate speech but censorship
runs both ways there are plenty of
examples of pro-palestinian students
trying to shut down pro-israel speech on
campus - in fact students from all sorts
of political groups try to censor their
opponents and university administrators
are all too eager to comply
so who's the biggest loser and the
campus free speech Wars it's a question
that's nearly impossible to answer and
one that ultimately misses the point if
one person's free expression rights can
be crushed underfoot by an overzealous
administrator campus security officer or
emotionally insecure student then
everyone on campus is in danger
since hateful and offensive our relative
terms we can't protect the kind of
speech we like unless we're willing to
also defend speech we utterly despise if
a person is offended by seeing a flag
what do you think they should do well
they should definitely voice that
concern I mean that's why we're here to
express yourself freely I do not think
that they should attempt to exploit any
university infrastructure or mechanisms
like the policing structure that was
that was the case with Romney to silence
those views in
open a conversation more speech less
police absolutely that's a general rule
in life